hey let me see if you guys can hear me
with this okay I bet you say that a lot
and welcome to punch-drunk sports you
know who we are you know what we do
joining us in studio is voted number one
favorite comic by punch-drunk Sports
Brody Stephens joins us everybody
[Music]
excited
reeling so much great stuff going on we
got ready bow looking dapper as always
Tebow Tebow would fit in like into like
their early for days when Ford was still
inventing the car I feel like you could
you could hang out with them okay that's
pretty specific and like you could hang
out with Howard Hughes back in the day
I'd like that yeah like that yeah no not
from Phoenix everything the guide the
rich guy who [ __ ] in a jar it was only P
o on black time all of us Kurt are you
Jew Oh guys look if we have to juice a
lot and a dude who looks like papers
please don't joining us in studio
o considered one of the top 40 comics of
New York City a very funny guy and we're
excited well you missed it I was voted
most likely to play out with Howard
Hughes before you got here so
Curt bat takes top 40 comics and that's
exactly what we said in the jar it was
team well they both do yeah they don't
both do probably because they both did a
lot code allegedly did they ever say why
he had to save his [ __ ] and P enjoys
like what the purpose was probably
because in his mind they were gonna they
were gonna clone him they stopped his
poop samples can you go
impossible people from there we get your
DNA from poop you can't get it from
urine you can't no railings ammonia I
was peeing in a jug for like two years
yeah you could not even clone you just
have a jug full of pet Mike's Hard
Lemonade on man just hit it up wasted a
lot of time oh yeah oh yeah yeah Peter
to a jug when I lived in New York can we
find options for what purpose
save trips to the restroom okay did you
live down a fall fire hall was it a long
walk for a young Brody
yeah it was it was one of those weekly
hotels in Bushman LA hi was there also
you live at the bush man yeah he was
like ah uh yeah he was not like in a
different floor it was a weekly hotel on
a hundred and 7th and Broadway dude how
shady are those weeklies it was Shady
but it was uh four it wasn't bad I knew
what I was getting into oh that was jug
full of piss I live in Hollywood and I
smoke crack and this guy tried to suck
my dick but Brody let's look up your
special define try to find try suck a
[ __ ] out of it was moved by her own rib
high on crack I was just saying I had to
have a rib put in to keep me from
sucking to help stop me from doing I
guess was their vote in the village we
got it stopped the sponsor it's like
biting your nails when they put that
stuff on you know I do mrs. Metzger the
reason we're calling you in is that your
son apparently only have so many ribs
and is constantly sucking his own dick
in class hey Ari put it on mute is he at
a weekly hotel
also I thought we were hearing a great
samples pertaining to oh he's doing an
interview yeah take it off turn him off
call back do I want to hear about him
and whatever [ __ ] cheeky Oh is that
always your fear or just mute him yeah
can we mute him we're witnessing a
situation here
this
might be a [ __ ] hey chris hardwick
quit that [ __ ] well he runs a tight hard
worker by the way yeah what have you you
know Chris always yeah what's going on
what's going on with him now
what is a conspiracy apparently he had a
relationship yeah and in this town
having a relationship warrant just
ripping two decades of work [ __ ] away
yeah only if you're see that's why I'm
safe yeah my bad relationships they're
just waiting for something to happen but
I'm like I'm gonna beat the system I'm
not gonna let anything happen I don't
have one ex-girlfriend I'm not friends
with yeah me type
I mean God I smile so do i I don't say
my even Danielle and I still you know
we're cool with each other it's not like
we're having lunch but she doesn't have
any ill it's unbelievable and then you
have all these female comics like piling
on it's like okay yeah you are she can
we turn that off you know what can we do
that okay so so you have a shitty to you
you you choose shitty men and because of
that people should have their careers
rip well I don't know any shitty I all I
got to go on is a but what I'm saying is
these girls who are these girls who are
simply ah thinking it's okay to destroy
Chris Hardwick
because they had a bad relationship in
the past is it Molly that's illicit
multiple girls that is the regular if
you have a like don't you think like
well one time I guys something something
what is that to do with this yeah yeah
that said I'm every woman [ __ ] and
uh it's like a a weird disease because
it's like I'm collectivizing my pain and
I'm collectivizing your guilt and I'm
like I know real with all the men like
oh part of it is like there's an
accountability element to it to where
it's like if you read her complaint it's
like he told me I couldn't go out to the
clubs and hang out with a man I couldn't
come home drunk cuz he's sober and you
chose and go okay I agree with those
terms of your boundaries by the way she
said I was expected so that doesn't mean
he said [ __ ] that could just mean
her entire [ __ ] see I'm not just from
reading a little bit of it it's like
that's not the kind of [ __ ] after three
years you have to come back I was
expected not to go out drink oh no how
the abusive uh uh not want to get
cheated on by your trophy yeah cosplay
over but it's honestly dude if I was
like crazy
ah one thing I will tell you for sure is
that she later on admits she cheated on
him
so everything that he did up to that
point was warranted in thinking that she
was gonna cheat on him mm-hmm cuz she
literally cheat was like hey don't do
this don't do why won't you do this cuz
you're gonna cheat on me I did cheat
oh okay so it's warranted I blame the
website for allowing her to write the UH
yeah blog yeah I'm joking but I go it's
not I mean somebody's dudes gonna [ __ ]
golfing one of these rich ass
[ __ ] but why can't I was pseudo
she said sexual assault to sue so just
so he knows I have proof of all this
stuff so if it goes to court I can show
the proof she said that yeah
proof of why oh yeah but okay last thing
she's number one she could probably
prove what she said but sexual assault
is not the thing she said like sexual
assault is sexual assault it's not I
felt pressured that he break up have sex
it's not sexual assault I know that's
like some new definition they came up
but in a court of law it ain't so yeah
and that's that's it's a huge amount of
like why but we're not dealing with the
court of law we're dealing with to a
quitter mob rule that's who makes it
well that's just a two minute hey dude
that's like AI 1984 likelies you are
gonna get the two minute hates yes we
got yeah but the two minute hate turned
into him losing that the AMC gig getting
off the panels and his career tarnished
I would like to see her I would like to
see her evidence and I know Chris
probably like just like oh I get it but
I just let it go man I shouldn't know
none of it I mean I don't understand why
this is
business yeah I should have a [ __ ]
opinion about it well I'll tell you what
my tinfoil hat thing I truly believe
social media has achieved consciousness
it's like what do you what do you mean
so hot what does that mean
it's a [ __ ] brain everybody got
together made a crazy brains a
collective it's a it's the ultimate it's
just tearing itself right now you're
getting mad electively it's an organist
opt because some people go like it's not
fair should be punished for anybody it's
like we don't want this person being
punished for this thing it's like okay
but not one person who's calling for
their punishment one person is writing a
blog and then the collective million
people reacting get pressure on to a
company to fire them whatever but it's
like it's not one person calling for
anything so it's weird it really is a
click no it's the be right in so I yeah
I am multiple t-bo's talked about this
before how I have multiple Twitter
accounts based on the different shows I
have right so I was on the tinfoil had a
cow and I look on to the feed of
following people who I'm following and I
see that says that my personal cow had
liked a tweet that I I don't even follow
this guy I don't even know who this dude
is I've never seen this tweet before and
it's a pretty like politically incorrect
tweet about how this guy says that he's
he's kind of conflicted because this guy
got shot once but he beat up his
girlfriend before so he's kind of
conflicted because he wasn't shot 20
times and like that's not me that's not
me I'm not that guy
but it's like a really weird tweet to
have suddenly liked by me when I never
even [ __ ] liked it and you feel like
somebody tweak the algorithm somebody
got into your account
that's what Twitter does now I'm sure
that Twitter if you buy BOTS and all
this [ __ ] and there's certain profiles
they want to promote that they probably
get you to follow people you don't know
you're following yeah I don't know I
wasn't
I made my hand slipped or something but
I don't want to follow anybody you know
you how many
[ __ ] people I mean this blows me away
to like in just in I don't last like six
months like a dull people not alright
like it's not like something wrong with
them but I've heard them complain that
somebody doesn't follow them back on
like a Instagram like it's a problem so
it's not like a child saying this it's
like a grumpy like yeah they don't
follow me back like well I just bother
me ha I wasn't saying Brody that I guess
up to number five now right but uh that
if you think about it or if I could for
in sesame all all my prose all my
problems in last year I've just been
social media like all my main problems
in life have solely been caused by
social media yeah since I haven't been
on that [ __ ] I feel like a goddamn
mountain man like I'm off the grid but
it's not done anything at all I mean I
put post shows up if I'm we're gonna be
somewhere but I don't go on it or look
at it or whatever and uh it's great like
so you Sam mutter to myself like a
homeless person before it was invented
we ruined Twitter or you talked to
somebody like why are you speaking to me
in person
well I would just mumble to myself and I
just went on that came out I would do it
just like out so it's like a little bit
better than just talking to no one and
then I went back to muttering to myself
and it's like the voice in my head it
definitely better no I think that
cacophony of nonsense before we answer
Brody's a question
I won't go around the horn where you get
a B Jason will do you mine last because
we got that show coming up all right
where are you gonna be Thursday Thursday
night June 24 senses go to Cobbs comedy
club us place I'm assuming Mexico's been
banned from as well all right we should
just do tour of places curtains I am
from I'm not banned from Cobbs oh wait
is that the one is that a punchline
related place yeah no no I just a
punchline here me Oh Molly's great not
sure you be a punch on where you gonna
be Metzger
I got a look you know what go to Kurt
mask of comedy calm because all my tour
dates are up on my website curb mask of
comedy calm Brody this weekend where
anywhere anytime Comedy Store I'm going
go on the road with David Spade that's
great doing
Ontario improv yeah I have a chance to
be in grown-ups 5 and that's great and
also if I may at the Comedy Store of
course and the Laugh Factory when I call
on fur veils and same goes for the
improv but I'm a local guy my mom is a
local I'm local
yeah I'm staying close to the womb
that's yet to do local Teamsters respect
out here I didn't know that I think oh
yeah there's a room he was a Seattle guy
I tell you till I die
yes I have the plot purchased Wow you
were thinking really far ahead I got her
vine improv July 12th oh [ __ ] dude [ __ ]
jump in city of my good friend Jason
Tebow where ha I will be at the Comedy
Store this weekend I will be at Hermosa
Beach doing the bones and buddies show
Sunday night I will be at the yarn barn
last month and I'll be at hecklers Haven
at the big heckle festival bring your
Tomatoes that's in Long Beach and it
starts at midnight and then I'm at slice
of death in Salem all of August of 2021
also we have our big UFC viewing party
July 11 q5f fire 26th whatever - 26 days
July 7th
we are you in town July 7 yes you would
you like to do a show you know boom
would you Brody like the new show
I send me the details okay yeah let me
look at them July 7th is UFC 226 and we
are doing a live viewing party at the
Sycamore tab awesome
followed by live stand-up upstairs in
the dojo so uh come watch the fights for
free and then it's ten bucks to get in
Jason Tebow Kurt Metzger right Brody has
agreed to do it we'll probably have read
ban on it too so grab your tickets now
there's only a hundred tickets available
ten dollars a pop grab your tickets now
and then of course following that will
be skank fast skank bag O'Neil and here
to talk about oh maybe Metzger talk
about this
things right can beat the show gomez
yeah doneall though uh he's a friend of
ours I have to see comedian I made that
fight happen really yeah I
because glues Gomez Ryan O'Neal would
always challenge either re er myself
fight and they're like way younger than
a challenge re because everybody punch
him in the face
but I mean what's the glory of of
attacking a 40 year old
what's the glory of not it's a three
[ __ ] Jew but what I'm say something to
prison wall like how did it come about
did you just say re did you do say
something to piss yeah I blame the
victim fear I fear this Kurt Metzger I
don't know if you guys know each other
but uh Ari's known as the amazing racist
and he tends to make fun of women with
without arms and his specials and stuff
like that tend is misleading is that
tattoo I just mean like I can't imagine
re like in an argument with them going
like I could beat you up at UFC it seems
like that's like how would it lead to
that being a thing okay well there you
go know everybody thinks they beat you
up re and you know Emily they're so fat
you will win you'll get gassed within 20
seconds of just standing up and then no
and then it'll be my victory to take let
me tell you so much is why I know for
sure from Dylan are I show you trying to
take boxing like with a trainer a while
back and I'm just getting in the proper
stance if I have to do that I get winded
and you will you win the fight like
never mind the fight just getting like
the [ __ ] together if you ain't supposed
to stance it like why did I wasn't
smoking for twenty years a patient of
getting hit it's ten times worse than
the actual head just like that is
literally the process of getting in a
fight I was my childhood yeah you know
how many fights you're getting into now
I think I'm 41 now no none zero I've
gotten to a lot of fights on this fight
sorry I mean
rody I'm sorry juice sorry leverage the
last time you were in a fistfight
south-by-southwest I went to a fire I
did see the video yeah punched elbows
are you my name what's the last age so
how old are you the last time that was
like my early 40s okay show me how you
punch
why did more of an enol bells at that
and a lot of knees I bet that video
still exists what was that ah no cuz I
did see the video of it of me doing
kettlebells no when you were at the
South by Southwest and you literally got
into a altercation with the heckler I
believe yeah this guy came after me and
even threw a tambourine at you or
something like that yeah he ripped the
mic out of my hand I was on sparks
energy drinks at the time oh dude I get
that yeah and it's not by Southwest yeah
they go yeah I've been in fights with
friends and stuff and push I mean yeah
it's happened you know I come from a
wild background you know I come I'm
Jewish white trash no just fighting with
Jewish white trash as I come into your
synagogue he's gonna burn it down he's
Jewish white trash you look like an
extra from like it used to be the
devil's double looks like a stand-in for
a dictator I've had a lot of I've had
some physical interactions the last few
years but that's okay as you say you're
the one last time you were in a fight
honestly swinging man or woman alright
oh oh this morning oh no man um besides
I don't think it's been a while like a
pushing shoving man I mean I jumped into
fights I'm just in tonight's episode I'm
you defended rape besides that by the
time I you sir have offended raped honor
I'm talking about when I fought a duel
to defend race yeah
why sir I'll tell you at the cellar were
you there
or JBJ was hosting at the cellar when I
got popped my ear no I was not cupped
his own [ __ ] pop I was like stage
yeah we're on the airplane Pandora no
just some random god box my ear I mean
it's crazy I cut his hand and [ __ ]
smack I got a 50% perforation to my
eardrum
it was it healed completely this did you
say something ovaries [ __ ] crap nope
didn't trigger him to do that oh so I
was on it you remember the thing where
it's like you the crowds fine but
there's like one drunk acting as if
warming but you're not bombing yeah so
the rookie move is to go too hard at
them right and then and then you throw
it for the whole crowd but yeah but I'll
I'll let them [ __ ] it up for the crowd
before I'll say anything right just in
case I can't stand when they're wrong in
there cuz like were you so mean the
person is just ruining your life so but
I just did some chunky some girl I
should have drunk her that yeah sock
right like way in the back and it's not
big room to sell it all so I'm trying to
do a clean set you know you're like
gotta stay clean those four fallows
don't you yeah so I have my phone like
on the fire alarm in the cellar like
just filming set right so it's always
tense with that [ __ ] so I'm like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] my thing up cuz they said he
had just ignore it it was going fine and
then I can't remember I go I don't know
if like I said yuck they all laughed I
go well maybe you saw commit and then as
you got those guy goes off [ __ ] you oh
no I go I said to her you're very
attractive guy just tell you that you're
beautiful and that's probably why you
think people want you to talk but they
don't that's the thing that they say to
you cuz you're hot right don't think is
so bad so patty cakes its patty cakes
that's how I I look guys like the most
like not a Nam in this guy goes oh I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up the guy next to her is
threatening me now immediately right but
I can't see them because he's like I'm
like dude getting a lot of fights you
guys whatever I win fights I said I
can't remember it yeah it's like I still
didn't say anything like crazy you in
the stage whatever cuz the I had the
crown on my side they were just drunk
[ __ ] so I went back and forth where
I was really trying to give this dude
out you know it's clearly just drunk and
like his chick must be hot he must have
to always go through this all the time
because he's an idiot
like he's so I get off stage okay and um
I see them I just want to see what they
look like I just had to see what they
look like because I was so aggressive I
like I couldn't believe I know I'm
smoking cigarettes I got a cigarette for
you alright so uh I go to look in it and
J was me
you know it was J was making fun of me
like it was uh the mood was fine like it
didn't this is where I kind of [ __ ] up
but so I go to get my phone I look at
the girl I go hey J I was right she's a
hot [ __ ] right and she goes don't call
me a [ __ ] and I and then that's I lost
my temper from that offstage now there's
offstage in the room while she was going
I'm I'm like this whole situation happen
cuz you are exactly a [ __ ] [ __ ] by
the way the whole situation
that's all I said what I said was no no
I'm calling him a [ __ ] I'm calling you
a [ __ ] so yes a dude just jumps up and
the waitress was trying to get between
me and him good security yeah
the security guy was reading his there's
like huge guys reading like summer
reading books in Jordan and Todd Merida
to run interference I wouldn't I mean I
would never put that on Todd - those
days are behind him yes special forces
skills degrade without constant practice
anyway the guy gets up comes walking
over and so I still don't get that it's
like Europe I'm gonna hit it off I'm
like I hit my head all the way out not
using your boxing stance
those are using my yeah I don't have any
that's the posture that doesn't tire you
out yeah I'm like just relaxing my neck
as far as I can all the way hey he's
coming over and so there was someone in
the way but they do just went around
like really fast to Papa
I heard my your I heard it like pop and
uh so then if you see a video of it it's
just like from a stationary phone right
and I I look so much like a Frankenstein
I've never more look like a Frankenstein
where I'm like you just see my hand out
like this you see uh stumble back the
other way and then I end up on top of
him and I remember I want to just keep
hit him as much as I could was my only
there's a last night I mean I will go
mad I'll do
how it [ __ ] it not big enough to be
doing that and I'll pop me in the ear Oh
buddy way anybody could beat me up I
probably would never get in a fight with
because they don't have a thing to prove
do you don't I mean uh-huh like it's
always like some guy like what do you do
that whole block is like that in the
village it's like these guys that you
can't believe they're threatening the
bouncers that look like they eat other
bouncers right it's some [ __ ] you're
just drunk
it's just drunk man so you've never
actually been punched well so so I'm
punch it they took so anyway Jacob they
say go and shake it call me [ __ ]
straight after because it took three
people to make me stop punching him
right so I always dude I was so I just
thought he [ __ ] made me deaf yeah but
I'd rather have his damage in my damage
like I had to go the hospital [ __ ] and
really like then water got in it was a
[ __ ] nightmare
anyway so the managers like go to the
hospital right now just because of Kafka
or whatever like you know you say you
went hospital for you
cuz I was even go to the hospital is how
stupid I was so I went then this guy's
this guy called the cops to say the
comedian assaulted him or his wife did
it make the news alright he is a [ __ ]
as his wife did it no no no but I'll
tell you how it ended up so so uh
because they thought it apparently was
only because I said [ __ ] like it's
illegal it's like totally fine you can't
fact I thought I'm like maybe I was like
Brian you know provoking it did you say
feckless come I said you yeah I put a
little Samantha anyway so uh the cops
show up so crowd can I go now he [ __ ]
box the guy's ear so so he just got
himself arrested basically this idiot
and uh did you just were you witness to
your own crime and sound like you were
just witnessing your own crime like oh
no I boxed him in there like were you in
like the crowd the crowd told the cops
and I they call me later but I know I
gotta take a leak give me a job I'm
gonna get him a job
goddammit yeah hi Bush man I'll be right
there so uh and then somebody said when
they she was saying [ __ ] like my father
could buy and sell this place like like
you haven't heard out to have an 80s
movie and then I was told later ski
school when they found a few
arrested one of the cops was black so
she can call him the hidden work and she
took a swing at him you need a reality
show so they get arrested I do go to the
running for president well I found out
so I go to DA with the video it's like
my whole set Dana then like the back and
forth and I think he had to pay my he
doesn't pay the hospital bill for me
except the time I did I'm insurance 37 I
have insurance but he paid paid for it
so how much was that who knows so
[ __ ] uh later I find out these were
when we were doing race Wars on Sirius
Mia Sherrod
one of the cops called in from that
night and with the arresting officers is
like two years later so that's how I
found out about her : that guy the
n-word and taking a swing at him and
then she ended up leaving the dude for
that black cop that she called the
n-word never found that out like to
usually talk about that on stage is his
name officer I did or his show and I've
told for is his name officer Uncle Tom
no he was like part Korean or something
he worked for the Daily News or I he he
I think like a graphics guy I felt like
kind of bad from like Jesus Christ cuz I
remember going like is this like a thing
where your constant getting drunk
getting in fights cuz you feel like you
can't hold on this like right there's
nobody hard enough that that's worth
alright that was the fastest yeah I'm
back I was fast
really why to go NASCAR you went NASCAR
in that piss you know I do everything
okay if I had girlfriend there that some
comedian called a client that would
never I've never had a date that creates
a problem like that in public I'd never
be like shut the [ __ ] up hey can we find
out do we have a trailer is there a
trailer for your special they excuse me
they if you go on iTunes I think they
have some clips if we find a clip of his
special because we gotta push this push
yeah we have the positive push I did my
late-night special comedy for Cecil
which I thought was an amazing company
that the worst business model ever yeah
like I I thought do they had toast of
London before anybody like I was really
I thought that would be good but you can
only get
on your fillings like how would you
watch it was part of Hulu and they
thought they charge you for Hulu and
then charge you for oh that's what it is
right oh I'm so my NBC so it's like why
do you just make that the dull air adult
section of Hulu I'm already paying $10 a
month let me get that for free and just
be know that oh if you go here it's
gonna get more adult more that kind of I
like that guy that was like though guy
running it I remember its rightful place
maybe I don't know I just remember I was
like yeah this would be cool but I was
like yeah what is it which one is it
neither one
neither one it's on iTunes if you go to
iTunes you can even go to my Twitter
page go to and see the I posted the link
alright but here's the deal I'm doing
everything on my own
I barely am able to survive with
physically no I'm kidding bottom line is
I did hey I did the special will find it
it's on there somewhere because I was
constantly getting that late-night spot
at the Comedy Store well those are fun
spots if it they're fun spots if it's a
10:30 start show it's not fun spot if
it's a 9:30 start show let's see can we
see viewing I do we won't look lights up
there with blockers Jumanji and game
night look at that dude we stopped being
a blocker after 22 years comedian Brody
Stephens fight that we're out of it
finally tapes finally tapes his one-hour
special filmed and created at the
world-famous Comedy Store in Sunset
Boulevard in West Hollywood California
Stephens assumes the Sam Kinison spot
leading this late-night audience on a
journey showcasing his unique banter
upbeat music classic jokes and positive
punchlines he part be part of this magic
moment sit back relax and connect with
Brody I think I wrote that myself that's
gonna acid you write that I think so
yeah you know this well I do the late
night closing spot I've been doing it
for I don't know six or seven years and
Tommy maybe six years Tommy gave it to
me the old Booker to get ready for La
Jolla
hey do you know um who got that spot
before you Mencia
no um Tripoli Oh very low the Sam
Tripoli spot wait but you don't want
that spot from the show you've got
comedy chaos and because I because I do
that spot Tim tinfoil hat came about
weird how the universe works I didn't
realize that oh so that's what it's been
the whole time no I see how it works no
Obama Tripoli spy Sam's conspiracy
person yeah Brody I'm hurryin I'm a
reality first I'm off my medicines busy
you know what you're partially right I
decide to get hammered and what like
what how how far out do you go what with
what like me choice of his dentist as a
ghost
we know he says me Stefan collaterally
if it was in the flattering shape yeah I
think that's what a guy named flattered
no I'm not a flat earther but I don't
care either yeah I think there's way
worse [ __ ] like what and flatter flashes
what just that the war on terror is
about making people's lives better the
war on drugs about keeping people off
drugs you know oh you're like Arab or
something when the war on terror is the
first skepticism that whole thing is
that's why I like these people in this
town who just like they're just such
conformist
yeah I'm over it I mean getting back to
the flat earth flat earth it's just it's
it's a popularity thing it's what's hot
right now it's like it's like the pet
rock yeah you get it flat earth pet rock
collection I love that went a long way
for that trip yeah it's cool well no
this town is great I think we under
dislike we're talking about
I guess Hardwick on the show it's like
this is it's like ridiculous we're at
the point now where it's just it's
kindergarten it's childish and those are
the hot in town do you [ __ ] think any
of these [ __ ] people that are online
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] about a real victim
of anything and it's about anything
except these weird it like turns them
into like cannibals but are you talking
about anonymous people are you Tom out
news people talk about comedians
yeah enacted obviously I got in trouble
for saying this was a [ __ ] scary day
the social-media mob [ __ ] it is justice
I literally got almost [ __ ] ruined
for that that's crazy to me but I can
see I was seeing in the way of some
great things because it was like a big
plan to bulldoze this through but I
think the [ __ ] actual brain itself
did it and and the people are just
incidental yeah I just think of all the
people that Kris hard work helped and
with that like at midnight and I was the
audience [ __ ] yeah I didn't see any of
them coming out we've been throwing oh
yeah well I know why cuz listen I got my
head [ __ ] chopped off for it you don't
stick your neck out for that just let
him do their [ __ ] bulldoze by the way
I was on the episode I did I'm not
sticking my neck out for no for cosmic
Cosby's been to take you to the ringer I
think red he did is a okay yeah dude I'm
not I'll never be that cuz by the way I
was on the episode we're already laying
got thrown off for some tweet yeah we're
entering the [ __ ] robespierre face or
the French Revolution like they're like
there's a it's slowly begun to become
like Salem witch hunt it's like well
I'll get you know Barry Crimmins you
know we do know witches exist it's not I
mean we know rapists exist it's not like
a witch hunt but in terms of justice
it's a [ __ ] you know it's like a mob
like a lynch mob but well the hunt the
problem with that is that when
McCarthyism happened we knew communists
existed but they were just QZ yeah I
don't write to you communists they
didn't you can't just punish someone for
their political blue right right right
what you can they do not but I mean they
existed so it was was still a witch hunt
and it's like you know say whatever you
want mean we rehash when we talked
earlier I mean dude nothing in that said
that [ __ ] you know Chris Hart was a
bad boyfriend that there's a [ __ ]
local scene he's a bad boy or a bad
judge of character
yeah I'd say that we could say that if
you read that first of all he predicted
she was gonna cheat on him and she did
by the way the only called or cut in
directly before they started dating
isn't the only reason the only reason
that he is having this right now it's
cuz Aziz browned his way out of that
[ __ ]
whoa yeah obviously in some on writer
section and you're saying that I I'm not
just a green eye I don't but your Sam I
mean I don't dude how many black Amish
never like cause he saved a lot of us I
know quite a few let me tell you
something dude they can only like only
feel good doing this kangaroo court [ __ ]
they're aware listen rosewood and Emmett
Till and all they they're aware of that
when you're like don't you remember
those like guys that or the Central Park
five yeah but what they're saying is
like we just it's this is just a thing
of sheer numbers of like hey if you like
white ones go [ __ ] which okay you can
say that but why am I supposed to agree
with it like you know what I mean like
why am I supposed to be on board with me
being [ __ ] over by a potential
psychopath liar which exist especially
in this business if someone's gonna be a
liar it's gonna be around this [ __ ] or a
custody dispute historically good way
can I go back to Z Singh so you're
saying like Aziz got out of it because
well I don't it's not anything he did I
don't think he did Shari said Brown
doubt I the media group big sister let's
call them yeah I like that
big sister Brown they bailed them out
they're just not gonna go on a brown all
around guy they're not but Chris
Hardwick because he's a white guy he's
not the pointiest knows you ever seen of
course he's going down dude Cosby had to
I know you don't agree with this but
Bill Cosby had to rape literally
everybody for them to go after him is it
amazing by the way I look took it as you
know and it's a bad story but just the
hopefulness of nobody believes a lot of
white women for a black man I mean
there's some progress right for many
years got away with it I can't believe
dude white people so much don't rat on
black dudes in this case and it's not
because black dudes haven't done
anything wrong by the McCue movement but
because black chicks understand their
inner Oakleigh harsh yeah and black men
have historically they understand us
have been overly punished for lots of
stuff so they're like hey look he might
have done something wrong to me but
these punishments are crazy I'm gonna
[ __ ] get a guy lynched over something
but it's not because they know that
white women are [ __ ] insane yeah
those are damn black athletes get
accused left I mean it like in
college football it's like yeah big I
don't know how this Michigan states
still have any athletic program with all
the [ __ ] child molesting that that
guy just got convicted up and how all
these bass Butler like football and then
we're all those the money cuz money
money to that ground it's just look dude
Harvey Weinstein how does that go on
when they what money it's all like as
soon as the so that's why this is an
influence I understand the idea of like
we're gonna do the same kind of
marketing to try to crack down you know
cuz they're like well believe women
doesn't just mean believe all women it
means you know women have historically
not been believed which is [ __ ] I
mean the only people who are dumb enough
to believe women are men by the way the
story lights who believes women women
know not to [ __ ] believe women women
know better okay and you can listen this
is the most amazing you can hear all
this [ __ ] solidarity [ __ ] I've had
literally friends talk about that in
this next breath then talk about the
[ __ ] they hate and wherever they work I
mean no like not even conscious of how I
hate women until comes the men well I
think I may be saying there's a bad
thing about women we're not in this time
not with the men so to be like I care
about women that's insane I know why
would that help you if all the women
ships are it it does a comedy especially
well they're like what how come there's
not enough spots for women you mean you
I could understand that but you want to
lower the value of you is what you're
saying to me which they don't they're
like to talk about their spots I know
women that are friends with other women
solely because they mutually hate the
same women that's their only I don't
have male friends that like I and I
aren't friends because we both hate a
certain other guy yeah listen there are
women that are friends just because they
both hate this other girl but the bottom
line is there's not any particular thing
of disbelieving women just sexual
assault victims in general are not
believed because it's a pain he has to
deal with if it affects your business so
Penn State for example that's not women
not being believed that's a bunch of
boys molested for years there no one
listened to the Catholic Church all
those boys there's no there's not a
gender thing about it sexual assault
victims across the board if there's a
money interest or people are gonna
protect their [ __ ] money first though
okay and instead of addressing that we
got to go with this third wave [ __ ]
feminists horseshit
I mean that is almost conspiratorial
that's insane some of this [ __ ] read the
actual [ __ ] they say it's crazy what
about the hot teachers with with the
students that's a whole night jerk-off
for them I know they're always so hot
yeah I may always have to look like what
did I go they shouldn't hire them in the
first place you're odd you're too hot
all together that's now a lawsuit coming
so you can't we can't get anyone to
teach kids but you smoky hot chick you
definitely can't fill that need yeah yet
I mean if you have a hot teacher you
know you just chances are she's gonna be
with no one I recommend wearing a burka
for men except people mistake you for a
Klansman so you can't really breaking
news yes I I do I have some breaking
news okay well then if that's the case
then I think we should we should have
some breaking news man go ahead and be
ready for that and we got breaking news
[Music]
Jason Tebow has put on the table a
proposal for on the bag of bats that I
think we should discuss right now and
really decide what we're gonna do
Jason Tebow would you like to present
your ID hold on before you die try
getting a [ __ ] USA chanted at a
[ __ ] Music Festival this weekend I
think there'll be an easy place I think
that would be an easy place what nice
try if you live in Donovan if you were
London Donovan you'd be like Mexico
Mexico that's a racist band name the
black he's the african-american reason
what was your favorite part of the
blistering anti-trump rap of mmm his did
you see that when they was blistering
Trump is gonna be covered in blisters
when he hears this rap the best point I
thought it was Rock now
I thought you're gonna say it's when his
eight black friends were standing behind
him quietly and respectfully that was
your favorite boy who was all at the
musical festival you're at
besides the african-american keys it was
Eminem Lil Wayne and Kendrick with a
blacks and then and then come on sue
Washington too but then uh killers blood
what's it called blood orange no blood
blood is a new orange yeah I forget hi
buddy
so where was the concert at Dover
Delaware [ __ ] Firefly music festival
oh you had to go all the way down there
alright alright so up there down there
from Brooklyn TiVo oh yeah I put on the
table if he was what if he was willing
to do if Sam will trade all the
outstanding bets no I will absorb all of
them you said two of them you SILS
wonder we won that one that one's not
happening yeah it is then you then you
have to do that one - no I don't well
then the bets off the table alright
that's fine
next week I'll have a hot dog in my but
alright when are you here am i doing
probably next week I have somebody come
in dude I won the bet that's not paying
it off [ __ ] enforcer of the rules of
the bets
it's it was always the next time I'm in
studio we will as soon as the bets over
we will do it that well it's always the
two losers do it at the same time yeah
yeah find that thing and read it when
you do the hot dog thing are they frozen
we because that was because that was
because that would that would numb the
anal lips that makes it easier right
yeah what what knows the analytic we
just say anal lips on punch truck I
don't the frozen the frozen kielbasa I
mean I've just been in Oregon what what
is gonna happen with it
we made a bat and the bat was whose team
would have a better record last season
in football our and I lost losers have a
hot dog
alright guys can't you just have fun in
Shopaholic up your ass that's what I'm
doing
you don't have to have this phony bet I
mean I was practicing months and months
without a condom got a condom that's a
good point what someone will grab your
back oh no it's just gonna get stuck in
your [ __ ] you got to wait for it to
thaw for like a month
yeah the rectal juices dog [ __ ] they got
away for the dick to go down yeah that's
a pretty graphic thing no III here's the
deal real quick getting back to all this
stuff we'll talk these relationships
that's crazy I think we are gonna hit a
rock bottom point where come on where I
think I think we're getting close your
life we hit it there's nobody in real
life so who do you meet in real life
besides the most demented [ __ ] you know
in your life that agrees with the
Internet [ __ ] like I don't really know
but he does yeah yeah so is this what
I'm saying it's like so we get
suspicious that people aren't even
involved in this anymore it's just the
[ __ ] thing itself like it's alive
dude you know what I read or you know
what I heard are two terrible ways to
start a conversation now because it's
gonna get you're gonna get some internet
[ __ ] that somebody heard it's almost
come full circle where remember back in
the day like a lot of people have jokes
about this like you used to not be able
to win an argument or you could you know
because what am I going to go to the
library and you would just be able to
lie back in the day yeah you can make
[ __ ] up great suckers hell a there's no
way to get back but now that you can but
you can look up anything you look up
right now dinosaurs are still alive and
real and they'll be article I see told
you it's a true it's not anybody could
write an article put on the Internet
right because you it's in print
does that mean it's real yeah yeah but
it used to you know the Dewey Decimal is
you know that because of that time dude
have you think of how bad how long it
takes to write a book and
cross-reference a book and have people
proof read a book and cross-check a book
any [ __ ] nine-year-old can write a
10-page article right now I'll fill it
full of [ __ ] doesn't mean it's true
they have now here's the other thing in
that day besides like you know having to
deal with all the amateurs I think
they're stand-ups that you know like
it's like a YouTube star or some [ __ ]
it's a comedian people put it to you
like it's what you do right
the same thing with these [ __ ] blogs
like the the real journalists have
[ __ ] completely they suck and they
just quality in the clock now online so
it's the same as like weird comedy
pretentious like journalists pretenders
and they don't do their [ __ ] job and
then the news just quoi
the reason I know is because I watch it
happen to me personally would it be like
some insane thing and then they're
[ __ ] right like USA Today like that
regular of a papers picking up crazy
[ __ ] yeah I mean I I you know I said
super I didn't even sue all the [ __ ]
people I just sue for the amount of slam
but I'm shocked at the level of not
accurate I guess I always knew it's
called fake news all the news another
regularly News what I saw firsthand is
they're full of [ __ ] so yeah now amateur
is yes so there's people make their
money off you know that's why this
shit's for any Twitter activism is
complete no it's locked out of the gate
okay because it's merely the way the
media keeps itself in business because
nobody's buying papers so they started
slowly introducing Gawker make like that
gossip element no that's the same as
news and that's just so they all this
when they probe me to they don't give a
[ __ ] about a [ __ ] victim they care
about propping their bad ass up for sure
they need a new outrage of fresh outrage
every [ __ ] week yeah you'll never
guess what so-and-so just did and then I
click it and I gotta click fifteen
[ __ ] ads alright I don't even read oh
so don't tell me it's grown even read
him just wait a week exactly one week
responding the cycle move on well you
think Hardwick kinda waited we know that
first day if you respond the first day
you're not gonna be doing it rationally
but you think Hardwick could have done
that on this then respond hard we could
have done that waited a week when all
they just took all this [ __ ] we're not
mocking a woman with a disability Ari
we're talking about not sorry about
mocking a 100 oh man we're talking about
serious [ __ ] in those a comment session
was like why they wait three hours if
you had nothing to hide by the way three
hours to respond that's because you
couldn't talk to oh yeah lawyers to
craft a response
first of all they're mad if you defend
yourself they're mad if you don't defend
yourself no matter if you say I'm wrong
they're mad if you say I'm right they're
like don't you dare ruin this you're on
Chinese it's you're a witch and so we're
gonna drown you and if you drown you
weren't a witch my bad but if you don't
drown you are a witch and then we're
gonna kill you either way you know we're
talking about Twitter you talk about the
social media but there's plenty look at
the news just regular news to 60 minutes
ABC the view I'm talking about the news
what's up no well gave you then you got
that but you've got that so you talk
those diapers you know who go I'm not on
Twitter I'm not on Facebook yeah but
you're watching the view like my mom
you're watching 60 minutes you're
watching you're in the so they're in
that then you got then you have the kids
who are all watching everything on the
internet and that's the that's the
scarier part but also that model will
collapse
well they don't read their here's the
thing that the clickbait headlines up
right but nobody actually reads the
[ __ ] this what I learned is nobody
reads the [ __ ] article so half the
evil [ __ ] that got written about them
like wow where'd you make that up from
nobody read it dude I mean like they
that's the really create oh by the way
I'll be can anybody tell me exactly what
Louie CK did wrong anyone does anyone
have any idea I've seen [ __ ] people
making out like he surprised jerks no
doesn't nothing didn't say that New York
Times article where are people getting
that what what did he do that's wrong
well I mean I've heard different thing
the biggest thing that I think that so
here's what I've heard dude is it's more
about his manager and his agents
pressuring those chicks and I know those
chicks they pressured him if they say
another justice agent
nobody said Berkowitz Dave Becky that's
what they said Dave Becky did it
pressure don't by the way so why energy
what did he do say it look like you did
not tell the story if it's how people
you're [ __ ] done that's what I was
told from the girls they say now later
on I hear some other [ __ ] went down that
makes me suspicious of some of the stuff
they're mad cuz they couldn't use his
story by name the way already did that
poor girl with the one arm
but but but there are you a story out
they didn't bring the story out oh he
was a new Greek guitar comics no missing
about but but but they didn't bring the
story out this story those brought up
right by somebody who had heard the
story in fact listen to the cellar
podcast you can the scumbag reporter
from the New York Times yeah
with I mean third wave [ __ ] big
sister [ __ ] all the way to her core
and no mass every question that I wanted
I'm like well it doesn't say he said hey
they says he didn't want them to tell
people that doesn't say he threatened
them see this is the same hardware thing
though the word told me the girls told
me that they got call from the manager
and said if they said anything they're
[ __ ] good by the way good that's a
great [ __ ] manager who are you don't
know if you want to watch hey Brody good
would you like to watch me jerk off I'm
not changing it that kinda are you ain't
changing it
they said he blocked the door and Gawker
that's how the story they never said
that I know the media manager did okay
but that's them but the the right are
the story this thing it's he's not just
saying hey do this say about this
devious thing that Luisa K did and I'll
finish you it's this it's like hey you
want a hotel with Louie CK after jerk
off in front of you you said yes so you
guys had a sexual relationship he's
married
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut what the
[ __ ] he asked if he could masturbate in
front of him right they're mad about it
common courtesy that might be told you
that he asked that's in the article 3 of
the for an article for the other four
admitted that he asked for permission
and they said yes so I never really said
yes the one on the phone I don't know
yeah that's the hang of it did every
single one of them is ridiculous but
it's because they got pressured by this
a very agenda-driven person it's a
Comedy Cellar podcast I camera the name
they report it but no god bless him he
asked every question I wanted to ask and
listen to what a worm because it's lies
of omission okay
it's leaving [ __ ] out so every single
one of those stories even with the lies
of omission which are a ton it's still
nothing that I needed to know about it
let's say he was even wrong for anything
which I don't think he's what the
stories he apologized seven years ago
that son of a [ __ ] and never did it
again
what the [ __ ] is everybody talking about
why did I need to know about it like why
would I need to know anything about it
now right because Gawker Nick Denton I
will my friend was working for at the
time when they got cosby with the
[ __ ] we don't need evidence anymore
Nick Dennis said find the next Cosby
because that's where the [ __ ] money
is so that's why the next corner hang on
follow Bill Cosby's business model who
said that so that's in there in the new
york 17 are you heard that they were
talking who's a mexican demagogue when
they were running the media that's what
they were talking about Oh many amazing
sports are going on right now
they got trouble I'm telling you Trump's
gonna get elected again probably and and
they're not like learning their lesson
this stupid [ __ ] is directly directly
what got it's not that everybody's a
racist it's not everybody hates women
because women voted for him too they
hate you they hate your [ __ ]
intersectional horseshit that much that
they'll burn the house down with you in
it you know very obvious I love the
World Cup I love baseball and I wanna go
see you live if you want to go to Russia
you can go see live go to see geek
SeatGeek you love segways yeah I do love
say go go see kick do go to the website
or download the app download the app use
the promo code punch drunk and get $20
towards your first ticket purchase right
let's say because we all see boxing all
the time we go see concert was last
concert you want saw I don't know but
I'm sure are you seeking seeking for
sure dude I just bought my tickets to
see bill burr at the Forum two tickets
I've never spent money on a comedy show
before and I bought him to go see a bill
to support him he doesn't need it but I
wanted to support him I'm super excited
go find bill you have see your sees come
into the staple center - yeah UFC that's
a big fight - Staples Center ah can we
find bill Bert's at the forum I'm super
stoked about it what is that show
September a bunch of me psych it does
like a whole week there or something no
I think he's doing water really it's one
or two why I think it's whiners it too
sometimes they do to shows the forum
that's [ __ ] Eagles played there
that's crazy he's doing so good yeah so
uh yeah he's pulling there I bought my
tickets - tickets ah are you going to
see bilberry you're going to see Dean
Del Ray be honest I'm just gonna say
that I think you know open for open
there's gotta be a music band I'm doing
four of them so go there man anything
you want I know we're gonna go see
boxing I know we got the UFC coming up I
know all that man i buy all my tickets
on SeatGeek anything was conscious I
just went to Braves Dodgers yeah we
bought it on see key right Johnny
Johnny's on his head yes dude so yeah
thank you see geek for all your
ticketing needs it's easy they break it
down based on best feels cheap sales
we're thanking them for their ticketing
needs yeah for helping us well if
seeking has ticket needs I'm sure they
know where to get it
hey Zeke accused the code punch-drunk so
this September it's September at the
forum
I think it's at 26 yeah I put in my
avails I didn't get I guess I didn't get
that day oh you put your valves to the
forum really yes I put my veils into the
forum stay hold spinner on Riley you
asked him why he did not book Brody no I
don't need to be I don't have been
involved with anything I'm uh you know I
do my own thing I'm from I'm different I
don't like to bring people down with me
Sebastian what joke do you think
Sebastian is doing right there with his
funny face day one watch Steve Martin
and what's-his-face on Netflix that's
great
I felt it was very much the other guy
more Martin Lewis Martin fetch or short
short yeah sure
he's funny so many comedians are doing
great it's a it's a it's a pretty cool
thing and I was doing great you are cuz
you got a special to just struggle
thanks I mean you've got to the boat
both those guys are 70 that was a pretty
[ __ ] impactful like high energy show
demine Martin Short yeah yeah it was
good I like roasted each other at first
who-who wrote those jokes we're doing to
roast each other they did it they're the
only two people credited as writers and
the musicians musicians credited with
all the music Jimmy Kimmel's piano
player
like a urinal wearing a weight where my
yeah yeah yeah yeah dude how about Jimmy
Kimmel losing to Ted Cruz in a
basketball game embarrassing did he
really yeah I mean 11 and 9 and they
were playing to 15 and Kimmel was coming
back and they cut it to 11 cuz they were
both so be are you serious yeah yeah I
mean yeah that's embarrassing that's
like what what what's worse that or
watching Judd Apatow throw a little
first picture to better game Kimmel does
not look happy who he banked it in do
they was Kimmel dressed in Carl Malone
blackface Jesus Road Road okay this is
good blob
Ted Cruz had good okay here we go he's
dribbling oh he just carried over that's
embarassing is the oldest man basketball
game I've ever seen in my toe we're in
Brooklyn
look at those two guys court this is the
white version of the uncle true movie
we're just two old people playing
basketball
it's 4-2 in there winded yeah a new self
is so tired against you yeah they played
that I like Texas Tech University or
something like that to a packed crowd
look at Kimmel he's like so sweaty he's
angry he's not happy there because you
get lit up now what are they arguing
healthcare yeah they really were Oh Ted
Cruz oh my god he posted them up got lit
up by Ted Cruz oh another shot Wow
another show foul dude everyone's like
Jimmy Kimmel's in trouble he's going
into this I really was positive Kimmel
was gonna win easily and destroy it yeah
I was gonna be you know you just I just
you know look at Guillermo he is not
Kimmel with a hook shot now you got to
win by two so Kimmel gets it to ten nine
and then Planned Parenthood Matt's got
how he blocked them that's the blobfish
mascot
yeah Kimmel has the shot oh did he tie
it there no that that goes nine ten now
what he is huffing he is huffing oh my
god this is in pretty good TV Isiah
Thomas was calling Liam refused to kiss
anybody on the oh you did a LeBron and
so Oh Kimmo Bloxom this is exciting
yeah oh my gosh did you see that shot
all ugly shots so anyway if Cruz wins we
don't get health care that was the
exactly that was the bet that was come
on really wanted for us Bruce won the
after parties at the Walmart hello
anybody yeah and then Jimmy Kimmel got
named MVP imagine that Mo's vet like 80
grand for charity remember Todd Tom
Brady sir
reality show where they had to reshoot
the end cuz they shot like he had one
and then they lost had to reshoot the
end this was like they thought Jimmy
Kimmel is gonna win so they just went
with the ceremony anyways we give them
trophies and thrown out yeah why
wouldn't Cruz get the MVP yeah part of
the gag
I was Jimmy's name on the engraved on
the trophy got a trophy I didn't see Ted
Cruz get a trophy in that bad haircut
Wow
I remember during the election I mean
they were to take Ted Cruz looks like he
shits a lot you look like a sea monster
who's yellow you look like a monster
just from the crowd I always be always
born in Cana I just think when are we
gonna say hey I mean Kanye did say like
can we try something else like the hate
and the anger seems just to be making
people more angry why don't we try like
dude like I'm being serious like have
gratitude but we don't well because
boy that's tone-deaf here I'll be I'll
be the feminist blogosphere okay well
that's really tone-deaf I mean all I
know
don't you Ord you listening women are
angry but mostly their lyrical don't you
dare try to reason with me
I'm angry Don feeding off my anger no
listen you don't stand Brody fairness
and all that shit's not gonna work we've
got to correct the historical imbalance
I'm not saying fairness historical
imbalance so what you do to correct that
is by creating an imbalance against the
people who created the original balance
kind of like how they take away their
right to vote again just like we're
doing how the Hutu did the Tutsi that's
what we're trying to do here but you
can't you're not gonna take the fire out
of people's uh you know hard online
online this is America sorry
yeah there's no vote here's what's
happening all this [ __ ] is I promise
are the amount of damage this stupid
[ __ ] internet [ __ ] did to people who
really got victimized is unbelievable
Trump's getting it I promise you he's
getting in the next I don't see real
quick why couldn't just okay let's say
okay Trump won the election why can't
they go whoever didn't vote for him ago
you know what let's work for the the
midterms or let's try and hold it at
some self-reflection just forget get
another can do people people not see
that's what she's on online like Trump
to me is the first female president he's
like he could dish it out but he can't
take it right he could say whatever he
wants but anybody but if anybody says to
him oh this is outrageous right the
Central Park five Hoover found anything
had their lives
I mean measurably [ __ ] destroyed by
what happened being wrongfully accused
being wrongfully convicted
Trump's still they did something he
sounds like a goddamn feminist after the
Jackie uv8 thing uh petty vindictive
tiny hands you know I mean he you're
getting exactly what you wanted that you
would have got for me what what what
basically they're perfect for each other
that's what I'm saying Trump and
feminists are the same person all I know
is what I learned playing baseball at
Arizona State we learned about positive
energy and visualization and an
affirmation same thing that I learned
playing baseball here in the San
Fernando Valley ad that's a typical
white whale things that but we just we
just won we just won we just believe
that I was around the Yankees they won
and you know what you could do with the
Yankees you could party you could do
whatever you want that's the thing
people and until cellphones came out but
people understand when you win and you
are successful people will look the
other way and you can do stuff but
people want to complain bring everybody
down now nobody gets to smoke pot nobody
gets to go I have sex with a it's it's
the bomb remember I think it was Louise
Joe gray but his daughters like one
daughter broke the other ones toy he's
like come on new watch like no break her
toy right that's the mentality I don't
want to fix the problem I want to break
your toy because my toy meanwhile I
didn't break your [ __ ] till I don't
even know who told you you had to make
everyone well that's where the parent
has to come in and go no the sorry I had
no idea it's it's really sad dude I had
no idea the Amanda collected a lot of
people yet cuz my parents told me my
mother told me nobody's got a right to
do that [ __ ] to you like tell you go
tell somebody immediately that never
happened with baseball I got Jew jokes
I got your gay jokes I got acne jokes
and you know what I was Jewish I played
baseball on Arizona State and you know
what I just took it and it made me
stronger and I knew by looking at them
it wasn't coming from a I could tell
when somebody was malicious and somebody
was just trying to push my buttons and
people go they said Jewish don't jokes
to you you better go tell your coach I
go no that's a good point dude because
there's inclusive like to sell it well
there's not really selling table it used
to be but it's in theirs inclusive
ballbusting it's that's inclusive and
then the the currency of hipsters is
exclusion so always I always these all
team people they were doing I'm not
going to a real club that's not why I
got into comedy because they they're not
into that kind of [ __ ] they're into
excluding someone and imagining that
somehow a kinder I think correctness is
simply all about let's handicap white
guys let's face it dude the rules of
comedy you can't do this show again
everybody does those jokes you just
don't want certain guys to do the job
you've literally handicapped it so the
people think you can't beat are not
allowed to participate
that's literally listen I'm probably
down I'll get around whatever your thing
is to say what I want that's fine but
why is it it doesn't bother me to be
caught like you're a white male whatever
say that I don't give a [ __ ] but what
upsets me is you told me that that
shit's like worse than murder right to
say to a highlighted thing so now you're
doing the thing to me that you think is
murderer so that's a little upsetting do
you know what I mean but I don't give a
the actual word it's what's behind it
but the Internet has removed context
that's the thing that that they they set
out to do decided to get rid of context
so that they can have these little power
trips because it's not or you really
like it's not the intent it's the impact
but usually in the internet but Arnon I
don't know you know there's enough
people Arthur or on the internet still
who are going no this doesn't feel right
when those people the the the outrage
the all this they'll be building they'll
be dealt with
they'll be slowly wiped off the it's
gonna be I don't know look at Israel
Israel's tiny I don't get political I'm
just saying like you want to come and
gone Punjab people that's right the
people that are the are the maniacs with
this [ __ ] are tiny all that social
jihadi [ __ ] those are that's not a
group of people that it's some [ __ ] in
like Portland Seattle people near the
tech industry mmm-hmm you know what I
mean like most of the country is like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about so
so there I think that's like Israel just
a small feisty thing controlling an
outside share like having an outsized
influence and that's just because
Hollywood traditionally live like but
you're gonna have people it's only gonna
go so far you know why because these
guys have good you don't want to go to
the point like hey listen this is that's
where it stops yeah well they're
devouring their own people so like the
al Frank right you just sit on the side
and watch it I sit on the side I wake up
every I wake up happy every day and I
love when people just going nuts over
stuff it was like I'm positive you know
it is better but I don't like the
[ __ ] order I want people to get along
together that's my thing and and then
they get mad at me it's like I wouldn't
I wouldn't bother you people for saying
that but for him Tripoli no I my my
balls have been cut off go ahead or
punishments it shouldn't all be the same
punishment you know I never did anything
I'm just saying anyway well Matt Damon
so is not even a little wrong but but
it's the unsaid [ __ ] this is the this is
what I love you trying to make me think
women don't lie and then the dishonesty
of every part of this movement like
they're like Matt Damon his insane
nothing he said was insane you mean
you're just mad now and he should have
known you're mad and you're stoking up
the anger to keep it going so you can
make a buck off it's not me my feelings
are amazed own deaths that's what's
going on these women make their feelings
feel like they're facts well look I'm
either dismissed
but why would you this is the understand
it's like the effort to look like you're
the good one is what's leading to some
of this victimization like like oh I
don't want to seem bad so I'm not gonna
advocate for my own [ __ ] body are you
out of your mind that wouldn't happen
would never would happen to my sister
because we weren't allowed to go to
parties and get drunk and do all that
[ __ ] we we weren't well Java witness we
[ __ ] we were such nerds they look
familiar knocked on my door knows you
have a witness we didn't do any of that
I didn't go to parties and [ __ ] I was
lied to date and any of that [ __ ] so we
got kind of protected you know I had
more options than you think but they
were cut off cuz I wasn't [ __ ] I
didn't realize the girls want to have
sex but I bet that you had a great time
if you want to make bets go on bet Diaz
I bet the aside for all of your betting
needs that's right go to bet the aside
calm use the promo pieces alright
25 and you can use all you can make bets
on anything bro well Brody's pot I'll
tell everyone I'll tell ya so can I see
I don't know any IDs I bet DSi it's real
simple use the promo code punch 25 get
$25 now let's say you make it to posi
put $200 in there
the people bet these are nice enough
they're gonna put four total they're
gonna double it that's how it is that's
how good is I make all my bets I come so
close to these parlays I really do I
don't work I get on that world come on
that welcome home by B Landon Landon
Donovan cheer for Mexico if that's
because you're butthurt II didn't get
put on the US World Cup team back when
we can't try that we qualified yeah do
it do X we go to our longest-running
sponsors bet D si.com use the promo code
punch 25 nice I was never a betting guy
I just said couldn't those numbers
confuse me I like to do too you know
alright have you been my name is okay
kept up on this
Kellen Winslow jr. story
you got fired as coach of the caps no
tight end played for the Box played for
a bunch of teams play for the Jets
Helen Winslow jr. his dad Kellen Winslow
senior was like an all-time Pro Bowl San
Diego tight end this guy's great this is
crazy
kidnapping and raping an elderly women
some of them in their 70s well six I
thought was the oldest okay
my mom's 87 so she's safe robbing them
kidnapping them for sodomy forced oral
sex and oral sex robbing them in what
order probably robbed them on the way
out this situation just went from ass to
mouth this is this is met this got to be
mental distal nurse bath salts it's a
[ __ ] predator by the way the that's
who rapes are a small group of repeat
offenders okay it's not all men is that
what it's very busy it's not an
education matter two counts of
kidnapping with the intent to commit
rape two counts of forcible rape one
count of forcible sodomy one kind of
forcible oral copulation separated those
two counts of residential burglaries
Hillary exposure on there just to say
[ __ ] it but he got busted for you know
back home in New Jersey low synthetic
marijuana that's right said like maybe
there's some bath salts because this
guy's already how many spice when
there's so much pot real pot around I
know you were back then he was still
playing and they couldn't tell where's
we're doing Oh missed that point this
guy's a [ __ ] football yeah is ex NFL
big-time NFL player yeah any like one of
the greatest tight ends of all time I
mean it stands in the Hall of Fame
people do it's because it doesn't show
up in a test so they're doing way
unhealthier pot yeah military people in
particular so they don't get caught
there they're making themselves do a
more dangerous substance so they can get
away with it drug tests should be alone
good CT be yeah CT this kid was angry in
remember in college goes I'm cuz I'm a
soldier man that's what you see them
like flipping out like I mean the brain
damn
these [ __ ] guys get must be intense I
mean the level of suicide for them is
super high the level of [ __ ] Lou
Gehrig's disease like all that [ __ ] is
like Swiss cheese brain living weapons
walking around like I mean the full
sodomizing your grandma come on football
players and these in our in our
wrestlers they should be taking care of
football players wrestlers and our
veterans we should take care of those
guys about comedians we can have a
little I don't [ __ ] watch football
and give a [ __ ] I couldn't give a [ __ ]
about it what sport do you watch very
almost nothing ever do you pay attention
like a you'll wear at least of what's
going on peripheral know why differently
is that where do I begin
why nobody gives that is the reason they
don't like sports do I just don't care
for bike a but I'm not a hypocrite I
don't know I just never got you know why
I was from Cleveland I was born in
Cleveland man was he was never happy on
Sunday I just never saw any joy come
from it from the Browns but what about
the Indians were you aware of like
what's going on at least like oh yeah
they're they like baseball you like it
now from what I understand now when
people tell me about it baseball sounds
like the one I probably be more
interested in just because of the
strategy involved but uh I like the
lifestyle baseball there is a lot of
strategy the thing with almost all the
lifestyle yes mean the flying around a
nice plane say a nice hotel
no no I'm talking about like going to
the ballpark early I saw Billy Durham
okay batting practice and spring
training and then postgame dinners and
talking and watching yeah the
preparation also just being around the
baseball stadium uh to be able to hang
out with the Cubs and the Dodgers and
the Yankees over the year so you only
hang out with winning teams kind of like
how re only backs teams of win
championships yeah I mean winning teams
are a drug debate so I'm fine with that
what my teams have historically won a
lot of championships I'm glad that oh
he's a shrewd Jewish investor put it
that way yeah I just and and here's the
other thing I did get to hang out cuz my
buddy was a coach of the Yankees and I
saw it back then the the Yankee dynasty
how it was like being a new
mark how they appreciated guys who spoke
their mind put their balls out and
that's what the players today you can't
yell at these movies play these major
leaguers say they're sensitive you can't
yell who yells it on I mean they're
y-you what you coaches get your freaking
head your anchor why are you yelling at
my dad to raise your voice in in comedy
or in TV but and and babes porch you
know you see these coaches going crazy
if that happened in Hollywood on the
sidelines they'd be thrown in UCLA psych
ward can we are 17 names that you just
made me think of a bet who will be the
next powerful man taken down by me - OH
intro oh people always talk about that
someone said the rock last time but I'm
like I don't know oh you pick whoever
you want
I don't know you can have your own
system Andy Dick I may have a one your
dick is above the law he's Steven
Seagal's I think with Andy Dick it's
built in that it's your fault if you
around but hasn't me - they made their
point we got it we will we'll chill them
like everything Oh wipe ur hands clean
reset button listen listen
it's instead of that what we're gonna do
is just keep going and going and it'll
be more and more men facing less and
less Conte and then so by the Holy keeps
going down it'll just be like 30 seconds
at a time
do they like murder suicides do they
like these guys freaking out watch the
first 48 dude all the commercials are
tampons commercials they like murder so
yes they're cool so they do that's a
that's a titillating why do you think
there's so many like you always hear
this [ __ ] oh there's this girl I hated
me some feminist comic in DC that [ __ ]
what's-his-name that oh yeah yeah yeah
she was her name I was you - it's kind
of hot but anyway she like hey I've
never met this girl she [ __ ] Franco is
that name no no not what's the guy oh
the nice Jewish actor but he wasn't
James Dean and Dean and then he was
accused of being a rapist or the porn
actor and then she had a defense this is
my favorite because they all are like
supposed to automatically say guilty
until someone they know and they're like
no this one's different that like are
you that stupid you didn't
I know she really is just a genius isn't
she like for then I'm reading this where
I have to defend her because it's like
typical Lena Dunham defends her friend
she's known for many years instead of
this sumbitch she's never heard of you
not supposed to find your friend that
youth it
honest to god you're not give the
benefit of doubt to someone you've known
for many years just cuz someone said a
thing what kind of friend would you make
friends defend friends I've had friends
do [ __ ] up things and I had to just be
like I'm Annie I made a mistake in the
room well I mean I wouldn't stand by for
a rape that's a bit beyond my limits of
being a good friend
all that listen I will not cover up look
I won't cover up a rape or help you move
those are my two policies a friend mmm
that's a pretty sad define covering up a
rape no I don't like the Joker out this
rapes I never I keep it that and that's
the thing when I do my stand-up I keep
it positive and HIV positive crowd and
that's the other thing when you're in
the and when you're in a comedy club or
a room or what have you they're not on
social media they're not on TV you got
them all together and you can thats why
comedy is popular at the live form
because the real stuff has come coming
out there you're seeing the energy
you're not seeing the tweets and crowd
look at the Comedy Store it's the number
one club in the country and the world
were there for a reason people are drawn
to seeing the truth they're drawn to
seeing like the the the the front lines
of freedom of speech man yes number
called me up when uh what do you think
listen man it's like in real life nobody
you know you think from seeing this [ __ ]
people are like it want to like come up
and kill you or some but nobody [ __ ]
comes up this I think I know and I said
shut up 9/11 liar and I hung up the
phone on it just keeps moving to the
wrecking ball just keeps going that's
how it works
yeah but you change us a wrecking ball
but later said to me well he's a
positive guy he is he's a very positive
guy I should I'd her Rob Shane's very
positive guy but he's in no but he he's
he's active on Twitter I'm not
disagreeing with what he says I just
think he's I don't know if he's a
positive guy I think he's like honest on
there he's pretty like gets emotional
you know I talked to him on he talked to
he's like a very uh kind of get his
number I'd like to crawl I'm gonna
cross-reference with Spade I want to see
where are it where very nice to me that
guy I wanna see where Brody's uh
allegiances are right now okay
Cobb's Dodgers comes up three two Cubs
Cubs over Dodgers I'm a cup car your
Dodgers have because I support Los
Angeles what this is a Los Angeles City
hat did by the way my friend is a coach
I'm you're talking about friends I'm
loyal to my friends and family so I go
where my friend goes in my heart yeah
I'm a Dodger fan I grew up here I also
like the Angels but in relationships and
reality and life and actual people
reaching out and giving me access
I support the Cubs Cubs let me they want
me around they request my energy I mean
I got to be in the World Series parade I
got to suit up and that's the other
thing that I talk about with sports when
you bring energy they like it and when
it helps with with audience warmup
I'm trying to bring energy to regular
people give it a shot try to be positive
a couple times I don't want to sound all
corny with the secret and it's easier
said than done but when I've done it
I've been able to do it you know I
that's what and I'm not bragging when I
show me what the Cubs or I'm not
bragging when I show my name on the
marquee I'm just saying I visualized it
and I put out positive energy why not
give it a shot because people are hooked
on fake out they're hooked on the drug
of that of outrage there it's like a
drug you get I used to go read salon
combat like just to to be mad I don't
know why the [ __ ] I did that but I would
reach it I doesn't like mmm yeah good
board or something and it's like a
funnel is emit sensation so about some
real quick I just got a text from Chad
sumac Oh Chad and he wrote this to me he
goes dude call me when you get a second
the old tweets about me saying the
n-word cost me a job in Chicago I just
found out do you remember that when we
made that when we did a joke about when
Chad thought he called in honor he was
we were in the car but we made him think
he was on punch-drunk yeah yeah and I
took that tweet down it was a joke I go
and Chad thought we were we were live
broadcasting yeah he got a lot of
traffic on that and then he kept
tweeting I did not say this and that and
this I remember that so the gig they
took it away
wow what gig what's what see me : what
club what's gonna call him right away
for the call in so wait what I
understand what'd he do that got him in
trouble then I guess when I said he's
something joked about then say anything
else you ever say the n-word re I don't
it's too decadent for me I don't I I
bought it I only say the family reunions
and when I'm voting we ensure are used
to do this great ceremony on race Wars
so I think the word has so much
negativity attached to it I just relief
OD or stopping yourself those are all
yeah right in vote stubbing my toe yeah
but what do you think about that dude
you are you I don't think there's any
magic [ __ ] words I think it's like if
I'm you know me tried had a rich boss
here's a guy who likes a nice double
double G oh there's Cory Booker's best
friend I played in a golf outing
yesterday he was here like kind of you
know whatever I don't know anything
about them but I do know if he's ever
president I have a picture so do you
just take pictures with random black men
that people think are important and you
just later I'm trying to find out who
they are I knew who it was okay and now
all of a sudden you're throwing random
black men first of all he was
light-skinned okay - I don't usually
take / - people take pictures with me do
you know when you're talking to stupid I
do my apologies my bob de Bono you pay
cause it's me boss it's just a new
straight a new stand bus do you buy
those shirt
precut or do you cut the sleeves off
before you leave the house what am I
punching down that look like that looks
like Jim Florentines older sir Ahri's
house Seacrest out
are you keeping up are you keeping up no
it's uh Kurt are you a good bad scare he
uh he's a racist car better uh racist
funniest comics face generation figure
so nicest comic some I used to be the
king of feminism well let's go ask us
where do you fall in on this Lewis J
Gomez versus Wright O'Neal fight do you
know about as a guy that's been in some
comedy fights
but if he trains in any possible way I'm
gonna have to go with him okay but don't
you think Lewis is on some kind of like
steroids or in performance-enhancing
drugs that's what I'm betting on what
are you saying he takes roids and
doesn't work out I mean he's not
shredded at all he's only taking
performance d h-- answers is what you're
saying yeah Ryan O'Neal he's uh yeah
he's a very funny comic done a great
podcast he's written for re for a bunch
of stuff written on for Steven it's easy
for a bunch stuff and he's pretty funny
and he got a black belt in Taekwondo and
Cena Jason as a black belt in Taekwondo
tell him how deadly that is you do it
means nothing it means you can beat up
another eight-year-old in a strip mall
[Laughter]
hey tae kwon do back in the day and I
made it to purple belt and we should
fight in tournaments and type on those
80% or 7% feet but if they're just
boxing think Taekwondo me
nothing no Arthur no there I'm ma but
just no ground-and-pound right well I
guess no elbows or knees but you can
punch him the guy on the ground can you
uh make out with them I think that would
be a solid move we started Internet
campaign what happen the most effective
kind of fighting it looks like they're
spooning yeah like a nice kiss on the
back of the neck to get out he tapped
out by cuddling who's gonna win this
cuddle fight the second funniest guy at
that table
oh my you know what I take that as a
comment writing out of people we're
running there's nine of us I stay in my
lane everybody being you know that you
know we're all unrecognizable I think we
Billy burst picture is the first
funniest guy in none of us are going to
argue that and the Margay we're beggars
re are you supposed to fight me buddy
[ __ ] chicken down for the third
straight time third straight can you
imagine the CTE what if it's our good
fighting rich have you been on skype
before do you know this technology I
like the stone up divorce roasted voice
rose calm is that what do you want oh
that's a promotion for that I think so
maybe when is that by the way or is that
already up it's a bunch of course they
put out see is it on Aziz's website well
you just dropped to fourth funniest haha
yes see saying is a chance
the boss just stand up in it and it
looks like you see what time is a guy's
what what boss was standing the whole
time while he's talking about what times
you open might get Gotham today where
you going D train to Coney Island are we
still on yeah yes let's go let's get
racist now is the time we use that sound
clip for something if one of them gets
bad brain damage from this fight do you
see any of them going on a rampage of
old ladies that's a good question I'm
talking an exposure I get all these
sodomy
I could see it helping both their acts a
little bit of brain damage see you can
get you know to CTE funny guy in a
sitcom like it's Corky's next door
remember when he used to be funny
there's not enough special people in
sitcoms that we really got to go him for
a little while there was stand by me
right or what was working Corki and then
there was the guy from workaholics that
I thought killed it Adam Devine is he go
right here the other guy there we go
they go curb hmm Louis looks serious
there Ryan never looked serious in his
defense so that's part of his mirai ins
got the camouflage well the fans that
Ryan is much thinner than Louis but
they're the same height it's so
interesting but they're like 40 [ __ ]
pounds different what do you mean how
much is Ryan image lose weight Lewis is
230 and Ryan says he's 190 yeah they're
gonna define the weight well if Lewis
stays on his die I'm telling you like
it's a hard loose is a fat Hulk as you
know where he becomes fat very quickly
what's his background Puerto Rican yes
yeah so it's gonna be using that ethnic
rage which means he's packing having a
[ __ ] razor blade glued to a
toothbrush somewhere it's not like oh I
think guys think white guys are afraid
of them so they really ethnic up their
ass thickness training with him look at
he's training with the baby right you
just hit a kid in his ear like he's uh
punching Metzger
is this from your fight at the [ __ ]
this is a beautiful this boy kept your
ears captain why would it be important
to you as a comedian too you know so
train for a [ __ ] massacre because
Connie comedy in UFC it's I mean Mara
okay but I mean always never done like
it's just a weird thing people want to
like dominated some [ __ ] we think
Corey's never fought anybody but he did
try to deport Mexicans so it's kind of
the same thing Bobby Lee Bobby Lee yeah
in a fight fight or just in a fight yeah
and I could probably lady I mean come on
they go to a fight at the wins fine baby
Oh turns he's in a cage it's just
Walmart I keep going back to that bit
now let's see because what happens who's
he fighting Steve Simone there no that's
that's the man he's fighting the fat man
Oh Robert Kelly it's a fat man bombs
right
Oh kind of much weird
gutshot there yeah dude do you see
boxing arrow Spence [ __ ] liver shot
that guy yeah that's such an interesting
punch cuz it takes like 5 seconds like
and that was the sports talk on today's
punch-drunk sports I think it's been a
pretty quick update on our on our last
week we picked teams the only team to
take a loss is Ari with Germany I
believe I'm Germany Ari's Germany oh
yeah am i Germany we didn't take a
Lawry's Russia you're Germany Germany
got wood tied I thought 2 1 Mexico beat
him too oh yeah dude or one nothing then
one by one go I can't believe Germany
lost Mexico's top they got a bad draw in
the first round moves like a baby
World Cup is taking place in Russia yeah
as Putin made any appearances will he be
of course he will dude he fought to get
that thing that's a big thing to get
it's gonna ours is that I think the next
one so they'll show Putin on they'll
they're ok with
26 cutter oh yeah dude that's how did
they get that well the Japan win japan
won japan won with their little tiny
legs they've got to once a nanny's still
alive I'm not dead though I understand
you're our England's up yap you got
Poland yep yep yep
ooh Nigeria is gonna play Germany that's
gonna be interesting
we know you remember you've seen that
old ad like the old Denmark one right
Denmark get some weird you get some
weirdo really like because I never
followed soccer you know but I'm like oh
like Cleveland and the Browns away you
know use it but as most we're in your
country is your team like that yes when
I'm like the Olympics this is the only
time national is like the Olympics all
year for soccer people yeah it's like
it's the only time nationalism is
acceptable World Cup also jump in
Olympics not yet country World Baseball
Classic
it's like volleyball world classics
anything at world in it you're allowed
to cheat Ryder Cup yeah but nothing's
like this the whole world loses their
[ __ ] mind for this Olympics you know
why they're going nuts cuz the USA is
not into it well we just imagine if you
understand that soccer is not our word
it's it's it's a mixture of Oxford and
something that and and they only change
it to football to be different from us
but soccer was invented by Britain it
was their word until they we used it
yeah they call it football
I thought they called football soccer
they didn't start say it again oh yeah
the short name is says yeah right and so
they just changed it to be like [ __ ]
America but we never made up the word
soccer to be like our fifth or sixth
sport I mean also who gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I should put that make that point
yeah I'm not into it I don't understand
it I'm getting honest with you I think
baseball baseball you have you have
stats you have homeruns you have wins
you have losses you have things you can
look at soccer or I don't know well they
measure it completely in
metric trafficked girls to the officials
that are FIFA the score it's like youth
it looks like there's no score but the
scoring is going on all fleshly in
Russia yeah Brody tell them about your
special I have special you can find the
album whose the world come on you could
find looks like the cast from gaudy you
could find the album on Amazon you can
find the video portion you have to match
it up no but the the stand up video on
iTunes it's Brody Stephens live at the
main room it shows kind of like what I
do it captured what I did that night
late at night after 12 and this special
was yet this is me doing my special so I
was doing my special I acknowledge I was
doing my special that's part of the joke
as well and again I was I do all these
loves me you got credited with writer
that's great you're a screenwriter now I
am happy for you screenwriter there's
good yeah Congrats Brody actor and
screenwriter who you Jamie Foxx I'm
doing it all and I'm producer guys this
has been puncturing support thank you
guys for tuning in I hope you enjoyed
the Sports Talk today it was a lot of
fun and we will see you oh that's what
this is tin foil sports